welcome to this video is our caught
again played them a number of times
grandmasters love Gucci Chuck strong
blitz player as you see from the rating
I've got slightly negative score against
him three out of seven let's see a myth
so as he's trying to go for B 5 maybe I
should switch gears him not go for
Bishop g5 and what about 92 trying to
set up a position that I might switch
with to c6 set up now my interesting I
was trying to prepare myself for a five
or C 5 so that i can easily play d5
having everything protected okay he can
do be five but i don't really think that
that's one of the sounder versions of
the bank oh and i can go esox of course
modern benoni
yeah not taking it sometimes you can
take it PA needs to take what the f bomb
but it's not really kind of insane now
let's just let's just develop some what
now he takes sometimes he takes is some
setup that I actually do prefer oh we
have here she takes this b5 ok may I
stupid on these six I should have played
a for at least if I intend to take with
the sea pawn I should have played a form
ok he's instantly giving away the
exchange which is which is an
interesting way to play it's a known
sacrifice of course the general type of
sacrifice is known because he gets
strong play on the dark squares
especially considering that I have
played h3 if I wouldn't have played h3
here if I could just take this move back
32 H 2 then probably this is not really
a a great sacrifice and here this is
clearly playable that's I'm not easy at
all to play for wide as he's got so he's
got many easy moves that he can play um
yeah I want to take it
Queen g3 rock f3 and okay it's it's
nothing that needs to be justified by
media tactics publicly can improve from
his pieces just Queenie 7 for example on
that 95 or something left take some time
he can give this check and play Bishop
e3 this might be an idea but I I wasn't
sure if this helps yeah well Luke f3 it
runs into 95 later but still I need to
get the Queen away from from g3 okay I
go going tween f4 here is going Queen
background but but still I once I want
some quick moves in here may be here
so how to play that I mean it would be
probably helpful to exchange the night
only 592 to f3 something like that it
might be helpful okay he's opening up
the beef I'll even I'm slightly
surprised by that but ok if he takes
Knight takes Knight takes bishop takes
and takes on b2 i take f7 don't know
yeah but at least I'm not behind on the
clock the position here is so it's a
good that I'm oh the boogie for just
around the corner don't know ok go here
and the g4 wow I didn't expect that I
don't really understand what's going on
to be honest ok here's some managed to
support the night let's just protect
this for a moment yeah
should I just double here may be here
night everyone III this could be an idea
i'm also always ready two to maybe
return and exchange the Sun especially
of course for this dark squared bishop
that that might be an option if he
threatens to to win an exchange back i
might just let him take it yeah like
here this this this is an instance with
bishop age form here nor the saying
right here yeah i give this I give the
exchange back thats it's not it's
nothing that I am I really fearing to
have four or yeah I must go that if he
takes I don't know Queen takes Queen
takes rook King take screen edge for the
screen g3 which should be okay I guess
yeah f4 is the week less than even yeah
check came this is something that I can
play that game has nothing to fear check
and here I've got Luke everyone possibly
look everyone f4
going to go here I can also just take
here but you can go to the G file ok but
it isn't this just mostly a check queen
here
I have a hard time to calculate get this
i can eat sits at age one but is this
really so so dangerous I have many
pieces around my king don't don't see a
direct director i'm burnin problem all
of this i didn't see it all here I don't
know turkey check
hmm
takes night x i'm going to take the six
day this should be quite good at this
one i can take on d6 threatening and
threatening Queen f6 and here Queenie
once made oh ok check check I am better
be but I give her some chicks no check
check gonna check check check check Oh
whoo that was 10 slack resigned I don't
don't ask me what was cool he got it
this came what do what the game yeah it
was very interesting i mean this this
exchange cycles just just valid you can
play like that and black has so so such
a good play on the dark squares that
it's it's clearly if clearly viable and
it's very difficult to play and a
practical game slide I just like to
understand or get to get some something
some idea about the final stages of the
game around here I'm ready to return the
exchange that's clear I have some
counter play against g4 and and sends
things this you played and here I hear
the computer gives gifts a gives an
improvement oh yeah it's a clear
provement generate that one which is
very normal but he can go here and
that's very strong actually we're
where's the Queen going I cannot go here
oops here
so I must play five check cheeks Queen
takes and now taking yeah and that this
is much better if applicant aches he has
the check it's quite quite good and
Queen takes it takes here so this was
winning for black check you take can't
talk though check Sharon and here i
don't know i mean probably yeah here i
can take on g4 but as I couldn't I
couldn't I didn't have the nerve to do
that yeah maybe I really can do that but
since always checks yeah I was thinking
that he can pin me ah yes he is also a
nice square yeah wins so I could have
taken known okay this up so this seems
to be good for blackjack and now the
computer a very cold-blooded plays King
f8 king e seven securing the king and
keeping the attack now minus minus one
it's not like a direct loss but probably
good but okay we both had very little
time so here the computer is saying
equal and here Queen D six riders
winning but it was it was super tough
check this is in fact it's a draw okay
look at seven is a draw then there's
probably some improvement no no no other
computers which is to draw it's probably
a fair result anyway but okay here Queen
g4 is a win but I cash a check its own
and here he is running into a mate he
must go here and this seems to be a draw
with the petrol check with the King King
being hunted catalyst
and again yeah okay he run into he ran
into this this is made check don't check
check use checkmate one mins away from
the mate yeah tense game i hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching